do you click pins you know where what I
know that's amazing I will I'm gonna bid
on one of them
you got your perspective Hey d-roc wants
more context and I'm like super unlikely
move 36 hours of travel but the Jets won
so it's Tuesday we left on Sunday
backstage at Melbourne during this
one-week trip to Australia New Zealand
Melbourne Sydney Brisbane and then
Auckland New Zealand super excited and
the stage 3,000 people here in Melbourne
lower energy than normal which means
I'll probably come out there a little
more thoughtful a little more setting up
kind of the tone and then as the energy
of the crowd gets going I'll probably
build build build build I think in
general I'm a builder with my talks and
I think this one will actually just come
tired the public start at the lowest
energy in a while so
so it happens
[Music]
do people understand how hard it is to
live your life for yourself to live as
your own boss and make enough money to
have a good life as a it's a 1% thing in
our society and everybody has this level
of entitlement
especially now trust me I'm feeling it
I'm the beneficiary of it but now that
we've made entrepreneurs cool the whole
thing's totally [ __ ] everybody thinks
entrepreneurship so easy it's just super
hard it's super hard to be good enough
to make that kind of money because even
though the internet sphere and everybody
in this room has the chance to do it the
problem is the Internet's here and
everybody here has a chance to do it and
supply-and-demand takes over I love
people who are like Gary but my content
it's not doing well but it's because
people don't get it I'm too ahead of the
curve no you're not wrong
you just suck you're not a head of [ __ ]
the market is the market is the market
you have 39 views on your YouTube it
means you suck it means it's not
interesting or Amin's that you're early
so many people that Gary I'm lost you're
not lost or 27
this is a long game and the opportunity
is substantial but there are two very
important things the world my friends
let me let me break it down very simple
for you the world plays in the middle
and all the action is an
[Applause]
I've penetrated the security for the
second time just to see you look I have
I have a confidence and I see myself on
the Forbes list in 20 years as I see you
in front of me but sometimes I don't I
don't put in the work so something
inside me is telling me not to work I
like my I lay on bed like like a stupid
boy without outing
well III tell you something real quick
the first thing that comes to mind for
sure anybody who wants to be on the
Forbes list is already in trouble no no
I mean it I mean it I really think that
that might be an insight that you need
to think about like to think about that
list well unfortunately my passion is
operating which is all about money well
it's not necessarily all that money
means that you love our Luttrell's can
you make by each state trading stocks
well you enjoy the arbitrage of knowing
something right and enjoy the process as
you okay
dude listen I make money but like it's
not like what drives me it's a it's a
byproduct of my process you might enjoy
the fact that you know how to read
weather patterns and you know how to
invest in agricultural stock or that you
might believe in Jeff Bezos 15 years ago
I would not beat yourself up if you love
stocks to make yourself think that you
only care about the money
well what if my source what if my source
of passion is legacy palaces
well it proves cars well then them
didn't do that I mean who gets the judge
just cuz I'm not into that doesn't mean
it's right or wrong you do you alright
okay thank you good luck Mike they say
thank you guilt was my strength you know
sometimes I feel like if I feel like a
room really knows me like I'll take like
a different angle like if I'm not bad
you know you know me I'm not gonna talk
about something that I'm not passionate
about so you know it's kind of like
having a conversation with somebody
you're encouraging to do something
you've got to try all different versions
right encouragement you know like I
always think about like my buddies who
like we're scared to like ask a certain
girl out I used to everything first it
was building up then it was like you're
a piece of [ __ ] and it's regret that
it's like whatever you know whatever it
gets it done the reason I'm so good at
what I do is for whatever reason I'm
really honestly I haven't spent a whole
lot of time on it I don't like my
circumstance and my parents as you guys
hear but like the only thing you're
dealing with is voices like what's crazy
about me if I was in music and Jimmy
Iovine and jay-z and like Beyonce and
Clive Davis and [ __ ] all of them were
sitting at a dinner right now and I said
bladder that and they all looked at me
said you're wrong the way my brain works
is cool you're about to really be
humbled like I have a very if I believe
in something um I'm just incapable of
hearing anybody else and what happens to
a lot of people that do new things they
do it out of necessity not having any
resources and desperation it then works
and then they try to pander to the
Machine and they lose the edge do you
understand but if there's something that
I have a line in the sand on its
unmovable and it's unmovable from the
highest levels and I knew I was part of
a group that would go visit Barack Obama
and I remember there was a conversation
in the [ __ ] Oval Office and I just
remember that
the time when I was like okay this is
forever at every level like a bomb
willing to pushed back on everybody in
this room you know in that environment
with like all these fancy people and the
president and the government well then
what room am I gonna be in that that I'm
gonna succumb to and and I and I and I
comes up in other places it comes up in
you know some of you you definitely
probably know this when I'm in the hood
in a studio and I have to go against the
green that's probably even harder than
doing it in the Oval Office because
Street rules are different than [ __ ]
you know corporate rules or politician
rules and I'd rather die I'd literally
rather die
I'd rather die on my own sword you know
[Music]
Carrie could you explain me hey Noah
what I sleeping for six hours a day if
you're desperately unhappy and you hate
your life I'm very passionate that
there's a lot of hours in the day you
can still work your nine-to-five job
which is eight hours you can sleep six
but guess what if you want to say that
your body needs eight awesome so now
eight hours of work eight hours of sleep
it still gets me excited to debate with
people what are you doing in those other
eight hours
the majority complain and watch things
or do things to escape from the
realities of their unhappiness and I'm
saying
don't hide or put your head in the sand
attack those other eight hours and
create content or create a side hustle
or a business that can change the
outcome of your unhappiness I mean a lot
of times people confuse my message I
don't think people need to be
workaholics or or or you know hustle
every minute I'm speaking to the
billions of people who complain or up or
unhappy on an everyday basis but the
fact that we have this thing called the
internet and you can go garage saling
and flipping or start an Instagram
channel or a youtube show or a Shopify
store we have options and I want people
to see that and the reality is most
people would rather do well in complain
or escape and I think that's worth
debating sometimes you gotta kick it
somewhere you can't catch the vibe
hi but we still stay on our grind so you
I'm living yeah we do this every time
sometimes you gotta kick it somewhere
you kick that so five Dell be smoking it
high but we still stay on our grind yep
so headed now to the Sydney talk which
is the biggest of the four talks on this
New Zealand Australian kind of tour what
I'm way more excited about is the
Jamaican bobsled pin just got a bid at
29.99 which is more than I paid for the
entire huge lot if you're not watching
trash talk link it up here guys you're
making a huge mistake
literally I mean it sucks that we're
going into non grow their sales season
so it's gonna lose some momentum because
I do love a good town wide garage so
that's actually a pun pack real quick
just this should belong in town in trash
talk but you know I like missing in my
content you have to look for town wide
garage sales that's when the whole town
does it that's how you get the 30 or 40
in like a four-hour period I you know a
hundred and a four or five hour period
instead of like driving 20 minutes and
1710 excellent anyway so that's the fun
fact my greatest score for 20 bucks 40
bucks I bought like 5,000 playbills and
when I went through it I found like
three Brooklyn Dodgers booklets that one
for like a buck 50 a pop the original
Pinocchio 1940-something movie like
thing that went for a hundred every
Betty Davis went for twenty a pop judy
garland's went for like forty to fifty
or do fun it was at a state sale on a
Friday in Chatham New Jersey I was on my
way to a liquor liquor meeting and I saw
the sign it was a little early as I went
in and I couldn't believe it first I
found a Huckleberry Hound like nineteen
sixties stuffed animal for like a buck I
was like bang game over oh so pumped
that's a quick forty on the come-up but
then I went downstairs and just saw like
80 boxes and I was like what is this I
knew nothing about playbills this pre
smartphone I just went in bought it took
me for like 20 minutes that load my car
bailed on the [ __ ] meeting drove to
my parents house waited for AJ to get
out of high school and like [ __ ]
spend like nine hours looking up [ __ ]
do you click pins you know where that's
amazing I will I'm gonna bid on one of
them I'm gonna wear a pin for a little
fun fact about today d-roc how to put
tape on all his batteries at the airport
in Melbourne on the way to Sydney the
other crazy thing is we didn't have to
get her ticket checked I was so weirded
out Norman I think I'm gonna I think I
can potentially fail at any moment
that's the beauty of being an
entrepreneur you're only as good as your
last at-bat so there's always a sense in
the back of my mind that I could fail
it's why I'm always really really
resonated even though I grew up a much
bigger boxing man and I'm still a bigger
boxing fan there's something I love
about mixed martial arts is that
everybody takes it out right like it's
just like and I think that if you're in
business for yourself I mean how many
people here are entrepreneurs and have
been for over five years successfully
like you know a lot of us know like it's
lonely as [ __ ]
like I woke up at 4 o'clock in the
morning this morning because there's
some [ __ ] going in my LA office I had to
cancel a trip to Hawaii next week for a
conference that I really wanted to go to
cuz I have to go to in LA and fix [ __ ]
when you're an entrepreneur you own your
[ __ ] you're a firefighter you're the
last line of defense I always think I
can fail it's the reason I'm great I
think it's like a fighter and you go in
there and you know that any moment even
if you're a much better fighter than the
other person one punch can change the
outcome and that's what I think
entrepreneurship is I wake up every
morning knowing that one punch that I
didn't see coming
could change the outcome of everything
that I've been doing and that puts me on
an edge that I like I like being a weak
and focused and and most importantly I
like that level of humility I genuinely
I promise you here out of every [ __ ]
person here even if you sit here and
your friend brought you and you didn't
like me you think I'm [ __ ] nobody thinks
less of themselves nobody thinks less of
me in this room than me I'd mean that if
I'm just unbelievably not high on my own
supply
I appreciate the admiration I understand
what's happening with me but I promise
you if you could read my insights on a
piece of paper I stand up here knowing
I'm not [ __ ] and tomorrow it can all go
away unless I continue to execute and I
I play on that edge every day and I
appreciate and I'm flattered but I'm not
[ __ ] abused
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so yeah so do you have
any tips on how to deliver an idea in a
way that really is a nice with an
audience my framework is do you first
believe in what you're saying okay I
know that may sound funny but a lot of
people do things for many different
reasons
do you actually believe in it do you
understand how you best communicate
right is it audio as a written word is
it through design is it publicly
speaking is it through video and then do
you disproportionally take into account
the psychology of the audience that's
consuming it and the distribution
platform that's delivering it
I respect the stage the same way that I
respect the Instagram algorithm I
understand that there's a platform that
is delivering the message and I need to
play within it and so for me it's just
respecting all these variables one last
question so one of your number one tips
so could you give me one thing I could
do that I could take away today that
would make
communicator mmm I would follow up with
people after you communicate with them
it's about it's about a feedback loop
and putting people in a comfortable
enough place to tell you the truth is an
unbelievably important part of that you
know but asking it's a really powerful
thing I ask so many questions
even in real-time during speeches which
is an unusual behavior so you know that
I didn't know was unusual it's just my
natural state to try to get feedback so
asking people and being okay with
feedback pro and con and trying to
calibrate it in yourself but to me it's
just a deep respect for the audience and
again I'm extroverted and high energy so
I'm always so worried that people think
that's important there are so many
people that are incredible communicators
who are massively reserved they just
found their authentic way to communicate
[Music]
I don't think you understand what this
level of content and impact looks like
in 12 years um being a young dude you
know like I may be 55 years old very
young dude and I'm gonna be 55 like this
you know like like you know like you
know it's funny I you know it's funny
like it's just like you know you look at
you know and how I see it is I look at
like rock and roll and hippie guys and
not that I'm rock and roll or hippie but
like you could got 55 to like the same
guy I'm like oh you're still a burner
right or you still got like like you're
still rock and roll I'm still gonna be
entrepreneurship and hustler like how
many gyms someone's you just so I have
like four yoga teachers which are easy
to deal with right but then we have
martial arts instructors that have
videos you can't jump I need to deal
with the two managers we treat them all
like family be there's so many things
that we do for them but then they cross
the line what line so I've heard of the
drink fridge and grab a drink and you
know all y'all pay for that later on
that never gets paid for like we have a
bar inside well there's no there's a
couple things I I understand a couple
things that I think are super important
to frame up there's no such thing as
employees taking advantage of an
employer there's things that cuz you're
fundamentally in control like it is you
can fire let what you what you're doing
like a lot of business owners are doing
is you're amortize about the costs you
know treating like family is also very
dangerous framework like as you guys
know I pump unlimited propaganda about
culture that's fine but like you know
treating like family in the way that
you're positioning it is is something
that I want to poke at only because I
think that people can either get
ideological or putting makeup on a truth
right so you know a lot of people say
well I treat my company like family and
I look at it carefully and I'm like yeah
of course you do because you're using
all these other
wrigglers to subsidize the fact that
your underpaying market or you like you
know even if you're not under paying
market you're doing it because you want
retention even if you're you know like
so you're doing everything for the
business and they don't own the business
and select my dad back to old school
used to get crazy like the biggest head
butts my dad and I had were about the
employees period by a thousand like the
one fight that I never actually won with
my dad only out of like I didn't want
him to die was I wanted to sell all our
product in the store to our employees at
cost and it just drove him crazy so when
somebody steals too many drinks you
fighter them I think the one mistake
that you're making in my opinion is
you're being ideological about what you
do for them to me when you want to do
something like not have them eat the
spinach anymore you make that rule and
you deal with the ramifications of
people walking out or not like life's
about alternatives if they can't get
free spinach from you they can go work
at another gym and get free spinach or
maybe not
[Music]